hey Mulan we hate to ask but can we
check in with our pal moo shu we've
missed him in the official trailer and
come to think of it we didn't see your
lucky cricket either we can't imagine
China's best warrior bringing honor to
her family without her two best pals in
tow so spit it out already Mulan where
are they the official Mulan trailer is
out and the Internet is buzzing with
questions about the upcoming Disney
live-action remake
where's moo shu where's Lee Sheng does
Mulan have a sister these are all
questions were about to answer keep
watching to find out why the og Mulan is
nothing like the live-action Mulan yes
[Music]
where is moo shu we surely weren't the
only ones asking about our pal moo shu
you know the guardian spirit of the foie
since mu shu is one of the best animal
sidekicks in Disney history many fans
were shocked when he didn't make an
appearance in the official Mulan trailer
the truth is with both frogs yes this is
nemesis mu don't even like me well
there's an explanation for that and
Eddie Murphy's not going to like it
Disney has chosen to keep Merlin's story
on the realistic side so that means no
talking dragons however a voice actor
has been cast as Milan's lucky cricket
so perhaps creaky will play a more
permanent role through the thumb it
would appear that a new character is
taking wishes place
commander Tong is slated to take the
place of Mulan's mentor Mulan has a
sister
another thing we couldn't help but
notice from the trailer is that Mulan
appears to have a sister this is pretty
confusing since the Mulan we know and
love is only a child hence why she felt
responsible for protecting her father
from harm's way little is known about
Milan's new and mysterious little sister
but we're guessing she'll have an
important role to play why else would
Disney choose to add her to the
live-action remake where's the music we
can probably all agree that Disney's
Mulan has some of the best songs ever
I'll make a man out of you
reflection a girl worth fighting for and
honored to us all our legendary hits
that spark instant joy well guess what
the new Mulan movie isn't a
musical although it's hard to leave
Disney has chosen to leave the musical
aspect behind and it's literally
heartbreaking
we totally expected to see hints of
Milan's greatest hits throughout the
trailer but there were nowhere to be
found
where is li Shang Lee Shang is arguably
one of the best Disney boyfriend's of
all time it's hard to imagine Mulan
falling in love with anyone but our boy
Lee but as it turns out li Shang has
been written out of the new script for
now it would appear that li Shang is
being replaced by a character named Shen
hungry who is described as new minds
chief rival he slated to fall in love
with relined by the end of the film but
we're still a little bitter about
loosing li Shang the big bad Disney is
notorious for its collection of powerful
magical and criminally insane villains
but there's one bad guy who gives us the
heavy doobies like no cartoon ever has
and that's Shenmue how many men does it
take to deliver a message
and since Shenmue is an easy person to
pick out of a crowd we couldn't help but
notice that he was nowhere to be found
in the trailer so after a little digging
we found out that Shenmue is being
replaced by a powerful which he villain
we never thought we'd say this but we
miss Shan Yu long hair don't care
when Mulan chose to take her father's
place in the original she knew she had
to fake it to make it as a boy so she
chopped off her long locks and went off
to war but when watching the trailer we
realized that Milan's hair remains long
and intact for the entire film instead
of biting the bullet and cutting her
hair the new Mulan simply ties her hair
into a top knot or simply hides it under
a big metal helmet grandmother fall
every hero needs a shoulder to lean on
and grandmother fall always kept her
shoulder warm for her granddaughter
Mulan but one quick look at the trailers
all we needed to see to realize that the
spunky and hilarious grandmother Fah
isn't a part of the cast perhaps Milan's
little sister will be taking grandma's
place as Milan's feisty family member
Mulan duty another thing we notice in
the trailer is Mulan faint
which is my duty to fight this is far
from being the original Milan's motto
the og Mulan doesn't want to fight but
she does what she has to to save her
father
it looks like the live-action Mulan is
going to be very different than the
funny and clumsy animated Mulan but they
do still have one thing in common they
want to bring honor to the family a
match husband found it's hard to forget
what happened to Mulan when she first
met her matchmaker in the 1998 film she
totally burned the house down and
brought shame to her family but in the
trailer we find out that Milan's parents
have already found her a suitable match
although there is still a matchmaker
involved in the process Mulan most
likely is going to be engaged to someone
when she runs off to war already a
warrior but if there's one thing that
really surprised us is how Mulan is a
total warrior before she even sets off
to war unlike the animated Mulan who
doesn't even know how to hold a sword
the new Mulan is obviously weren't the
best soldiers in the Chinese army just
look at all the flips she's doing that's
not something a newbie can pull off so
are you guys excited to watch the
live-action remake of Milan in 2020 tell
us in the comments and that's a wrap hit
that subscribe button and give this
video a big thumbs up if you love Disney
thanks for watching the things we'll
catch you later
[Music]